で まあ雑談だからまあまあ読んで終了いたします
全ては不完全なので人も不完全
ですから失敗は当然に起こる
失敗のない人はありえないし
ないと思うなら大嘘つきですよ
自分の失敗を隠すが 他人の失敗を余計に大きくして世間世界に言いふらすでしょうに
それ性格悪いんです みんな失敗しているのに
だから自分の失敗を隠すんですね
性格悪いんです 自分の失敗を隠すくせに
他人の失敗だったらオープンアート
ヤタアブサンってブッダの言葉なんですけど
あのもみ殻のように この向かい風の中に人の過ちを世界中も振り回す
まあ言いふらすという
もう人間かと聞きたいんですけど
人の失敗を批判していい気分を感じる
よく人を批判することで自分が正しいということを観察的に言ってるんですよ
自分も失敗者だから 相手の失敗にも共感できるはずが
それだけはしないでしょ
誰でも失敗の経験があるんだから
人が失敗するその気持ちがね
理解できるはずなんです
でも我々は人の気持ちわかりたい
わかりたいと勝手に言ってるのに
あの失敗した気持ちだけは共感しないんですね
なんでお前はという態度になるんです
要するに人は鬼の心で生きている
慈しみっていうのはないんです
無知な人は失敗を批判して無駄なことをする
それも大失敗で 新しい失敗も失敗も招くと
無知な人はね まあ失敗を批判して批判して
さらに失敗を大きくするんです
これは愚か者のやり方
智者は処理方法 解決方法を与えたり
教えたりする 部下が失敗したところで
上司が智者だったら あのね
こういう風にすれば失敗しないんだよと教えるだけ
あるいは君は失敗した
君にはこれ処理できんだから
まあいいですよ まあこちらで何とかしますから
気にしないでくれと言う
それは智者のやり方は
無知な人のやり方は もうカンカン怒って批判してとか
自分も他人もみんな失敗に陥れるんです
はい これで終わり  質問などございませんか？ 質問
質問というよりは感想なんですが
今日のお話を聞いていて
自分の瞑想に対する取り組みがすごく当てはまるなと思って
それで なんか知らないうちに瞑想が壊れるというような
なんかそんな変な概念みたいなのができて
あるいは過去の 例えば調子が良かった時に引きずられて
やっぱりなんか今日は良くないなとか
なぜか意外とその過去にずっと瞑想がうまくいってないなと思うんですけど
それに対するアドバイスは
あの瞑想の場合は これは明らかなんですよ
過去と比較すればするほどダメになっちゃうんです
瞑想っていうのは その 10 分
その 5 分の出来事なんです
ですから この ダメっていうことは出てこないんです
本当は まあ基本的には一応観察することだから
今日の観察は何点でしょうかというふうな考えた方が
よろしいんですよ だからダメと思っても
本当はその日でしっかり観察していた可能性もあります
みんなこの気分がいいか悪いかで判断していますよ
気分が良かったら今日は瞑想うまくいったと
これって瞑想じゃないんです
まあ寝込んじゃったら瞑想でないんだから
今日はダメでしたということを言ってもいいんですけど
それははっきりしていますからね
このあの良かったと判断する場合は
この微妙に似ている場合もあります
だから寝込んじゃった場合は
もう仕事終わったばっかしで
もう調子は出てこないし
まあという自然な現象もあるし
だから別に失敗だっていう必要はその時でもないし
まあ今日はこういうことになったんだから
今度の瞑想では眠気入らないように何とかしますという風に
それ次は失敗なくなっちゃうんです
それ以外はあまり失敗っていうことは言えないんです
特にヴィパッサナー瞑想の場合は
だから観察はどこまで何点かっていうことなんです
だからあの心理は心理だから
瞑想であろうが世間であろうが同じ心理ですよ
ですから まあ今の瞬間で何やるのかというね
で そこを理解していけば
結構うまく上手に瞑想はできるようになるんです
ね  今の瞬間ってことなんですが
今の瞬間というのがあることはわかるんですが
なぜこう実感が得られないんです
うん それはやっぱり将来か過去に行ってますよ
気持ちが うん うん 将来と過去というのは時間があるものじゃないんです
だから心が もうこれは訓練でどんどん時間せめなくちゃいけないんですけど
ちゃんと過去に将来に行かない場合は実感があるんですよ
例えば 私はあの これからどこか行かなくちゃいけないし
それ考えながらこうやっていても
これを触った実感がないんですよ
だから これ見てギザギザしているんだから触ってやるぞと思っちゃうと
全部それ感じるでしょうね
しっかりと ですから 将来過去に行かない場合はいつでも実感があるんです
実感があると なんとなく気分もよろしいし
うまくいきますよ 仕事は失敗しないんですね
それだけのことだからね
例えばこれが触ったところで
こちら棘があると仮定しましょう
それは今の瞬間で生きていないで
これ触っちゃうと 人と喋っていて
何か言ったことで緊張したって
手をじっとねじるとかで怪我するでしょうね
それは時間ずれたんだからなんですね
失敗は触る 触ってやるそうと思って触っちゃう
棘があること知ってるんだからね
怪我はしないでしょうし
だから普段危ない危ないということでも
我々触ったりすると危なくないのはその時実感ある時なんです
実感がずれた途端 もう危ないんですね
これ 子供のケースではよく見えるでしょうね
はしゃいで遊んでいるんだけど
まあついついもう実感忘れちゃうというね
それで落ちたり怪我したり
しちゃうんですね まあ時々川の水をじーっと見ていて
面白くて面白くて 目がそちらに行っちゃうし
自分が危ないところに座ってるんだよってことがわからなくなっちゃうでしょうね
あと落ちちゃうし 落ちても子供にはそれなりに自分の身を守ることできますけど
あまりにも別なことにぼーっとしていたんだから
今何が起きているかって実感がなくなっちゃって溺れちゃうんですね
はい だから実感がないことっていうのは危険を招くんですよ
それはいつでも今の瞬間から時間
時間がずれた時起こるんです
はい  他質問ございますか？特にないようでしたら
皆さんの回向の御礼を
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に大拝敬し
回向に慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナーの修行によって得たこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖先 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らすますように
そして解脱を得ますように
サッビーティオーイワジャンツーサッベローゴーウィナッサトゥマーテーバワットアンテラーヨースキリーガーユコーバワーバウォトゥサッバマンガラーンラッカン
トゥサッバデーヴァタサッバブッダヌバーヴェーナサッバダンマヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダースッティバワントゥテーアビワダナシーリスーニッチ
ャンワッダパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティーアーユワンノーสุขアンバラン
サーリプッタサーリプッタ
では 長い時間どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました